hey um donald trump
almost fell flat on his face at a recent
rally
in londonderry new hampshire again
raising questions
about donald trump's balance and other
uh supposed symptoms that could connect
to cognitive decline or frontotemporal
dementia or other conditions that there
there are discussions of donald trump
having but even before we get to that
donald trump is now
just having rallies he's having rallies
as if there is no pandemic
he had 1500 or so people at his
rnc speech no masks no testing
no social distancing and not only was
the rhetoric of the rnc
indicative of a pandemic that's in the
rear view mirror
the actions were as well and donald
trump now
is simply resuming rallies large rallies
rallies without social distancing and
rallies of course
with uh some arrests uh
a number of different arrests taking
place
after donald trump's londonderry new
hampshire rally but first and foremost
so here is donald trump
uh walking up a a set of stairs
to give his speech and as you can see
donald trump uh sort of losing his
balance
and just narrowly avoiding falling flat
on his face and of course as people
watch this
a lot of speculation about donald
trump's balance and fitness
we all remember donald trump being
helped down
a ramp when he spoke at west point just
a few months ago
speculation about cognitive decline all
of these questions continuing to run
rampant and certainly donald trump
almost falling down
it certainly could be nothing i'll be
the first to tell you it could just be a
bad bad set of circumstances uh taking a
wrong step or whatever
but certainly with everything else
that's been going on with donald trump
bragging about his great score on a
cognitive test meant
only to identify very serious signs
of cognitive decline dementia etc not
particularly inspiring of confidence now
once
trump got on the stage it didn't
actually get any better donald trump
ranting and raving about
all sorts of bizarre things another one
of these just humiliating events
that really is as much of an indictment
of the crowd who will clap
for anything at this point as much of an
indictment of the the supporters
as it is of donald trump here is donald
trump with a very
strange rant about protesting ass
you're not mishearing me talking about
his ass this is the president ladies and
gentlemen making no sense
you know what i say protest is your ass
i don't talk about my ass
so this is an extremely low level of
discourse
it's a crowd that will cheer for
anything i i don't really like this term
i think it's one of these stupid terms
that
trump has latched on to for a little
while but the idea of the npc
a non-playable character from a video
game
that just repeats the predictable
pre-programmed actions no matter what's
going on around them
that's what i think of thanks to
trumpists who introduced me to the term
that's what i think of when i see people
clapping for anything
that donald trump says later in the
rally donald trump said people have no
choice
but to vote for him and that he really
doesn't have to be
running for president anyway i guess he
is continuing to say that this is a
favor he's done the american people i
guess take a look
up every family and every neighborhood
and we will fight for every vote we have
to win we have no choice
can i be honest with you okay look we're
working hard we're all working i don't
have to do this
i could get off that beautiful plane it
used to be black and white
with a red stripe that was mine
but that's air force one you know i get
off that beautiful plane
i could come up and say ladies and
gentlemen of new hampshire you have no
choice you have to
vote for me because if you don't you'll
be put in radical lefties you'll have a
depression
now of course remember we have an
economic
uh uh recession depression
now under democrats these are just the
facts we could debate how much they
matter we can debate correlation versus
causation but if you look historically
under democratic presidents stocks do
better but stocks aren't really
an indicator of the economy at large
unemployment is lower under democratic
presidents
gdp growth is higher under democratic
presidents
job creation is stronger under
democratic presidents
you can argue correctly that on too many
issues there are not
real substantive differences between
your average democrat and your average
republican
that's a fair discussion to have but
these numbers are clear
so the fear-mongering that the stock
market will implode if joe biden is
president
that the economy will implode that your
401ks will be worth nothing that
unemployment will explode that taxes
will quadruple
none of it is borne out by the f by the
facts
another example by the way of how easily
the trump crowd will just do whatever
trump says
trump attacking or mentioning chris
wallace from fox news
the crowd booing they will at the drop
of a hat
turn on whoever take a look at this and
one person i think was chris wallace
nice guy he's actually a nice guy
he said that he didn't have the same
energy in the speech that he usually has
well it's a different kind of a speech
tonight i'm in new hampshire and we can
wing it
so notice how donald trump's entire base
i mean for
for years fox news was their friend fox
news
was their ally and mostly fox news still
carries water for donald trump
but notice how quickly the entire base
turns on whoever including fox news
this is a sign of a cult that what the
leader says
is not questioned and adhered to we
spoke to cult expert stephen hassan a
few months ago
and it was one of the signs that he
talked about and then lastly donald
trump insisting that the protesters
aren't protesters and they don't even
know why they're protesting
they're not protesters those aren't
those are anarchists they're agitators
they're rioters they're looters they're
not you know you say that
and some of the people not all of them
but some of the people back there oh i
do
how dare you these are friendly
protesters right
friendly property
they're just looking for trouble has
nothing to do with george floyd has
nothing to do with anything
they don't even know who george floyd is
okay
they don't know who george they have no
idea
if you ask them who's george floyd they
couldn't even tell you these are just
bad people troublemakers
and they shouldn't be representing our
country
at important events and we've got to
stop it
so we're going to talk about the
protests
the inciting to violence of protesters
by the trump administration
in more detail later on in the program
but
what you have here fundamentally is
hostility towards people exercising
their rights under the first amendment
in a way that donald trump doesn't like
that's what this is
and i'm going to talk later i don't want
to get ahead of myself
of why inciting them to violence
is beneficial for donald trump's
reelection campaign that's coming up
later
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show
for more on this and all of the other
stories from today's show
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
cal tech scientists with only one
mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away and get rid of the
vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get
20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical